bon ça c'est nouveau numéro 17 8
sociétés nous allons parler une
structure unique en son genre en france
installée au sein du commissariat de
trappes ses épaules et psychosociale
alors pour détailler les actions de ce
pôle quatre intervenants en plateau
d'abord jean louis chapuis bonsoir cette
commissaire divisionnaire vous êtes
adjoint de la direction départementale
de la sécurité publique
le polo psycho social a été mis en place
il ya cinq ans autour de trois personnes
qui sont autour de cette table serge à
roanne bonsoir de la déléguée de la
cohésion police-population gabon soir
six collègues et voilà mokhtari bonsoir
vous êtes intervenante sociale à leur
premier fils jean-michel plus tout
simplement pourquoi avoir créé ce pôle
il ya cinq ans est-ce que ça répondait à
une demande à la fin de la population
peut-être des fonctionnaires de police
ou alors ce pôle a été créée
effectivement il ya cinq ans mais il est
le résultat d'un procès ce qui a été
plus long puisque dès les années
quatre-vingt dix-neuf des médiateurs
sociaux étaient vie travailler au
commissariat parce qu on se rendait
compte que la réponse pénale que nous
commissariat nous pouvions apporter qui
a la réponse type j'allais dire d'un
policier est bien étaient insuffisantes
pour essayer d'appréhender la totalité
du problème pour apporter une réponse
complète aux difficultés au-delà gisante
c'est à dire que c'est à dire qu'en fait
les situations de détresse que nous
connaissons et de violence qui nous
parviennent et qui parviennent
d'ailleurs par plusieurs canaux souhaite
par le canal de la plainte soit le parc
par le canal des patrouilles la nuit qui
rencontre effectivement des familles qui
se dispute violemment et bien toutes ces
remontées d'informations il fallait les
traités on pouvait les traités bien
entendu sur le plan pénal
mais encore fallait-il
appréhender le problème d'une manière
plus large et voir s'il était possible
sur le plan social d'apporter d'autres
réponses ou en tout cas en complément à
la réponse pénale qui est finalement
déjà la nôtre en tant que policier
et pourquoi trappe ça a été le hasard on
sait pas ce que vous allez rencontrer
des gens qui étaient disposés à valence
et ça c'est aussi un problème de
financement bien entendu il a fallu
financer ce psycho social qui existe
depuis cinq ans mais effectivement le
financement est plus est pluriel un
financement de l'état ya le concours
aussi des collectivités des
collectivités locales est tous assez
monté à trappes effectivement ça a été
le lieu de cette première construction
et vous le disiez tout à l'heure il
s'agit effectivement de quelque chose
d'unique en france actuellement
ou presque unique en france en tout cas
la conjonction de la présence d'un
travailleur social d'une psychologue et
d'un référent police population
justement c'est vous le référent police
population comment c'est fait la
rencontre entre vous trois entre une
psychologue une intervenante sociale et
et vous et bien cette rencontre s'est
faite naturellement
trois fonctionnaires travaillant les uns
à côté des autres dans des domaines de
compétences très très différents et un
regard en fait qui un jour eu un jour a
mis en évidence le fait que on pourrait
mieux travailler ensemble si nous
regards étaient croisés sur chacune des
situations plutôt que de recevoir les
personnes en des temps différents donc
ce regard croisé a permis d'aller
davantage vers la cellule familiale en
particulier puisque notre travail
principal et l'accompagnement des
victimes
70 % des dossiers vous traitez sont des
dossiers justement de violence le
lancement au gia les violences
intrafamiliales effectivement et et en
dehors de la procédure pénale
il est nécessaire d'avoir
un regard sur la cellule familiale pour
pouvoir peut-être mieux mesurer les
raisons pour lesquelles l'auteur est
passé à l'acte par exemple et puis de
pouvoir mieux accompagner les victimes
parce que on oublie très souvent qu'il
ya des victimes collatérales tels que
des enfants est souvent une histoire
très difficile au sein de ces familles
qui nécessitent un accompagnement et une
orientation vers d'autres partenaires
dont concrètement comment ça se passe
est ce que il faut que la personne
dépose plainte pas forcément il suffit
qu'une main courante qui était fait pour
que vous interveniez oui effectivement
il ya le canal de la date du dépôt de
plainte quel canal le plus classique
néanmoins certaines personnes dans ce
milieu des personnes qui sont en
souffrance dans le cadre intrafamilial
ne souhaite pas déposer plainte parce
qu'elles ont peur des conséquences que
cela peut avoir sur l'évolution de leur
famille et c'est la raison pour laquelle
elles préfèrent faire des mentions de
main courante
ça n'est pas les encouragements qu'on
leur donne on préfère qu'il y ait un
dépôt de plainte parce que les choses
seront plus circonstanciée la mention de
mains courantes étant un pis-aller est
d'ailleurs la police se réserve le droit
et le parc est d'ailleurs lui aussi se
réserve le droit de faire prospérer la
mention de mains courantes en une action
véritablement judiciaire d'ailleurs
qu'il dépose plainte
à partir de là vous proposer les
fonctions de police propose d'avoir
accès à ce pool psychosociale alors à
partir effectivement là la personne qui
est chargée de l'accueil au commissariat
suggère effectivement ou demande à la
personne si elle souhaite parler à
quelqu'un du politico sociale la
question a systématiquement poser est
bien souvent la réponse est là je parle
sous le contrôle la réponse est oui oui
oui c'est systématique à chaque dépôt de
plainte demain courante ont fait on
demande si on veut rencontrer le pôle
psychosociale alors comme on commence
par faire de la prise en charge de la
personne
on prend attache avec les usagers on
prend rendez vous avec lui on le reçoit
dans nos bureaux soit madame morel sur
moi même
le sieur entre rennes et cancale réponse
vous pouvez
apporter lors c'est une écoute où il ya
vraiment une action derrière
alors après mois pour pour ce qui est
effectivement mon domaine de compétence
l'idée c'est vraiment de d'offrir un
espace de parole aux personnes à
l'intérieur du commissariat
un petit peu en temps de pose aussi par
rapport à tout ce qui peut se passer
autour s'il ya une procédure un dépôt de
plainte
ça veut dire éventuellement interpeller
l'auteur la mise en garde à vue pour la
victime allait aller à la rencontre de
lui-même j'ai aussi parce qu'elle est
l'unité médico judiciaire ou mn où elle
va rencontrer un médecin
donc il va aussi lui poser des questions
procéder à des examens et c'est vrai que
lorsque la personne un peu pris dans
cette procédure
ça peut être extrêmement déstabilisant
voir un petit peu voire très intimidant
et moi je suis là pour proposer aussi un
peu un temps de pause de réflexion
d'apaisement pour pour la personne et
puis lui permettre de réfléchir à sa
démarche est aussi envisager la suite la
procédure ou l'après main courante ou
l'après police tout court et c'est
également mon travail que d'orienter les
personnes
s'il ya des problématiques d'ordre
social qui se pose de les orienter dans
ma collègue donc madame mokhtari pour
essayer d'avoir une approche la plus
pluridisciplinaire et la plus complète
possible
deux des personnes que nous pouvons
recevoir beaucoup m'a aidé chaque fois
qu'on propose aux personnes d'avoir
accès à ce pool psychosocial ont
peut-être disent oui donc ça veut dire
que ça répond à une vraie demande est ce
que ça veut dire aussi que du coup c'est
vous pensez que sans ce pôle s'est des
victimes parlent n'aurait pas osé
franchir la porte du commissariat
allez voir ce qu'on appelle
l'institutionnel qui des fois peut faire
peur parce qu'on connaît mal après je
pense que les gens à partir du moment où
ils franchissent la porte du
commissariat
il ya deux possibilités soit ils ont une
idée assez précise de ce qu'ils veulent
faire donc je veux déposer une plainte
jeu
des posing courante parfois on a aussi
des cas de figure où les personnages
mais ne savent pas exactement soit ce
que la loi prévoit pour les infractions
qui les concernent
soit elles sont dans l'hésitation parce
que la différence entre une plainte et
une main courante par exemple qu'est ce
que c'est donc nous on peut être là
aussi pas seulement pour être dans les
coupes mais aussi pour informer pour
guider les personnes pas non plus en
leur imposant des décisions qui ne leur
appartiennent pas mais surtout pour leur
donner toutes les clés tous les éléments
qui vont leur permettre à près de
prendre leur décision en connaissance de
cause et mais ça c'est pas le rôle d'un
fonctionnaire de police
quand vous être reçue au commissariat
d'expliquer sur la différence entre main
courante dépôt de plainte la 2-ème tête
manières ils ont peut-être pas le temps
les fonctionnaires de police
oui vous les fonctionnaires de police
n'ont pas forcément non plus la
connaissance de tout le tissu social qui
peut exister dans la ville et auprès
desquels effectivement les personnes
peuvent être utilement adressé il ya un
tissu social important et d'ailleurs le
rôle du du référent police-population du
délégué police population pour employer
le terme exact le rôle du délégué de
police population c'est de faire un peu
l'interface entre ce réseau
ce réseau associatif qui existe dans la
ville et les services de police se
répartir un petit peu les rôles alors
dans le réseau associatif il ya aussi la
maison de la justice et du droit
il y a le centre communal d'action
sociale et le policier qui s'occupe du
droit pénal ne connaît pas forcément
elle n'a pas forcément des relations
dans don dans tout dans tout ce milieu
associatif
vous l'avez dit à 70 % des cas sont des
violences intrafamiliales
extra-conjugales qui travaillent
conjugale qui sont concernés ya aussi
quel autre type de demande
toutes les demandes du public
la clinique le hic c'est à dire que le
public vient spontanément au
commissariat donc certaines parce
qu'elles ont été victimes d'infractions
pénales mais d'autres tout simplement
parce qu'elles ont des questions à poser
pour obtenir eu d'abord un lieu d'écouté
mais aussi à une orientation et
nous avons des questions de tout ordre
c'est à dire qui dépasse nos compétences
qui ne sont pas du tout inscrite dans
nos compétences mais auquel cas comme
par exemple un problème de logement par
exemple voilà tu as fait don qui vient
de se présenter au commissariat en
disant l'avoir trouvée salubre mais bon
ces personnes là ne savent pas toujours
vers quel institutionnels se tourne et
ne savent pas précisément qui jet set
cette compétence et notre travail c'est
justement de mettre cette courroie en
place pour leur dire qu'elle compliquait
le partenaire ils doivent contacter et
comment les contacter ce que je fais ce
que je voulais dire également c'est dans
cette démarche de propositions de mise
en relation systématique
c'est une démarche proactive de la part
du commissariat de police c'est à dire
que nous n'attendons pas que les gens
viennent nous rencontrer nous allons au
devant de ces personnes puisque cette
proposition de mise en relation
systématique est faite à tout le monde
même dans le cadre des appels 17 de nuit
de jour et c'est nous qui reprenant
contact avec les victimes
sur un thème qui a été définie par la
victime et c'est nous qui reprenant
contact avec ses victimes à cette
victime peut venir au commissariat pour
nous rencontrer dans le cadre d'un
rendez vous mais nous pouvons aussi la
rencontrer à l'extérieur l'extérieur du
commissariat c'est à dire que si la
personne est gêné de devenir dans un
commissariat pour rencontrer une
intervenante sociale une psychologue ou
un délégué cohésion police-population on
peut la rencontrer ailleurs on les
rencontre parfois au territoire d'action
sociale de la ville nouvelle où ils
rencontrent parfois en mairie on les
rencontre parfois sur des centres
sociaux il n'y a pas de lieux
spécifiques à cette rencontre
s'il y a une demande particulière de la
personne et puis en même temps où on a
mis en place une nocturne pour pouvoir
rencontrer ces personnes là en dehors de
leur temps de travail
éviter qu'il ne perde un après midi où
une matinée de travail
donc on met en place des nocturnes saas
avec fréquemment cette note lionel à lui
une fois par mois et on reçoit les
personnes entre 18 22 heures mais le
fait que les gens demandent par exemple
d'être reçue plutôt en extérieur comme
ça arrive assez régulièrement et ils se
sont
quoi plus rassurés ou enfin quelques
mois ils s'exposent - d'après eux nuit
après oui alors ils se sentent plus
rassurés nous comme ça on peut leur
expliquer les procédures qui peuvent
être entamée suite a donc un dépôt de
nantes rue de mâcon quand on leur
explique aussi la différence entre les
deux et du coup après ça peut les amener
donc à se rediriger vers le commissariat
pour justement entamé une procédure
et ça ça arrive justement où de fait par
une femme victime de violence qui osent
pas déposé plainte et qui finalement va
aller jusqu'au dépôt de plainte après
oui mais c'est un conte prenant souvent
le cheminement de cette personne ou à
aller vers le dépôt de plainte il y à
une situation où il ya une écoute c'est
un diagnostic est posé un diagnostic qui
est posé sur la situation
et petit à petit au fur et à mesure des
rencontres cette personne a abandonné va
aller dans le déprime et vous les suivez
pendant combien de temps ces personnes
il ya un délai à respecter ou vous
l'esquivé tant que la situation est vrai
que le véritable indicateur par rapport
au suivi c'est quand on sent que la
personne
on prête à accepter une orientation
qu'on va le faire parce que le
commissariat ça doit rester un lieu pour
ces personnes un lieu de passage dans
lequel ils vont pas voilà rester et on
va les orienter vers les partenaires
extérieurs
mais pour que cette orientation aient du
sens il faut que les personnes soient
prêtes à aller vers un autre
professionnel donc il ya un travail qui
est fait aussi par rapport à 7 à cette
orientation
donc il n'ya pas de gérer qu'il ya pas
de règles extrêmement défini mais en
tout cas l'idée c'est que le
commissariat ça doit rester un lieu de
transit de transit est-ce que ça permet
aussi par exemple aux fonctionnaires de
police de murs comprendre et connaître
leurs populations souvent gêné par
exemple interviennent sur des faits qui
sont très marquant très fort après ils
vont sur d'autres interventions là on
comprend que le rôle de ces trois
personnes permet d'exposer un peu plus
les situations peut-être de mieux
comprendre aussi
oui moi je crois que ça permet surtout
effectivement de mieux comprendre la
psychologie des gens qui à la fois sont
les victimes est à la fois les auteurs
ça permet d'aller plus au fond des
choses ça permet des échanges assurément
entre des gens qui ont une origine qui
est l'origine des travailleurs sociaux
et puis les gens qui ont fait qu
tivement une culture on abuse beaucoup
de ce mot là ma faim de culture
policière stricto sensu
je voulais également évoqué le fait que
ça nous permet aussi de résoudre les
phénomènes de l'urgence madame mokhtari
me disait il n'ya pas longtemps et je
trouve que l'image était bonne une
personne une femme qui a pu être
violenté dans son couple peut venir au
commissariat et ressortir sans qu'elles
y aient pensé à l'avance avec un
logement mis à sa disposition pour ne
pas retourner immédiatement chez elle
alors effectivement on n'a pas évoqué
cet aspect de l'urgence je pense qu'il
faut dire que la présence
de madame et ça risque c'est un fort
mouvement parce qu'une falloir bien
porte qui vient au commissariat
évidemment pas forcément est en tout cas
la peur peut-être de retourner chez elle
voilà les conséquences voilà ça peut
être aussi à son dépôt le fait qu'elle
ne sache pas où aller way ou si elle va
être mise à l'abri
ça peut elle a freiné dans son dépôt de
plainte donc dû quoi peut-être pas osé
parce qu'elle va se retrouver dehors
avec ses enfants
donc elle elle va hésiter mais là le
fait qu'on puisse la mettre à l'abri
elle va aller jusqu'au bout mais depuis
cinq ans vous êtes connu je présente à
peu près 1200 dossiers je crois traité
sur l'année beaucoup un travail toujours
et au quotidien pour nourrir ses liens
avec les partenaires extérieurs nourrir
ce dialogue et faire en sorte d'être
visible autant pour la population que
pour les partenaires avec qui on
travaille sur le territoire on a parlé
des victimes mais vous intéressé aussi
aux auteurs d'infractions pénales et
vous m'aviez cité en préparant sa pensée
l'exemple d'un travail qui est fait
aussi avec les établissements scolaires
en cas de violences ou dégradations au
sein d'un établissement scolaire alors
comment vous intervenez la drogue par
exemple travaillons pas avec l'ensemble
des établissements scolaires mais avec
certains des établissements scolaires
rabat la ville sur la ville de trappes
oui sur la ville de trappes maintenant
notre service va s'ouvrir sur la ville
nouvelle
nous travaillons avec certains chefs
d'établissements scolaires et avec eux
nous mettons en place en fait un
protocole qui est relativement simple
qui est pour les enfants qui commettent
des infractions pénales en parlons de
violences qu'ils commettent par exemple
des violences en milieu scolaire et pour
lesquels il n'y a pas de dépôt de
plainte dont le procureur de la
république ne sera pas informé
il n'ya pas dépôt de plainte parce que
les parents ne souhaitent pas déposé
plainte l'établissement scolaire traite
en interne bien évidemment le le
phénomène de violence par
l'intermédiaire de leurs réponses
spécifiques et en même temps nous nous
faisons un accompagnement de ceux de
sept adolescents et de leurs parents en
les rencontrant soit dans
l'établissement scolaire soit en dehors
de l'établissement dans le scolaire donc
au commissariat en mettant en place ce
qu'on appelle un rappel à l'ordre c'est
à dire que on remet en perspective le
cadre pénal pour cette enfant on lui
explique pour cet adolescent
signalement des adolescents on lui
explique précisément ce que sont les
éléments constitutifs de l'infraction
qui là qu'il a commis et on essaye de
travailler avec les parents pour ses
parents puissent relayer notre discours
accompagner cet adolescent pour éviter
qu'il ne vienne à réitérer l'infraction
pénale
on ne travaille pas seul entre a
également aidé partenaires ces
partenaires sont par exemple la maison
des adolescents de trappes où il peut y
avoir une incidence à la parentalité ou
un soutien à la parentalité où on peut
mettre en place également de la
médiation familiale où il y a également
une psychologue spécialisée qui est là
pour écouter et éventuellement orienter
ou soutenir les parents et ce travail
termeer en tout cas pour les primo
délinquants les plus jeunes permet
d'avoir un résultat tout de même très
très tangible c'est à dire que on nous
dit c'est le retour que nos qu'on nous
fait certains établissements scolaires
sont apaisées parce que il n'y a plus
ces passages à l'acte répétées de
certains de ces adolescents nous
souhaiterions pouvoir travailler encore
davantage avec les établissements
scolaires c'est plutôt sur le sénat
c'est sur le volontariat des états et
sur le volontariat du chef de
l'établissement scolaire
et ça vous le ressentez aussi sur le
terrain ses effets positifs sur ces
jeunes voulaient recevez ils sont un peu
tous sur buzz je présume
alors après c'est vrai que
moi mon grande partie de mon travail du
moins sur cette cette partie la
démission c'est aussi de dialoguer avec
les parents puisqu'on est véritablement
dans une approche de la famille et pas
de l'adolescente d'enfants de façon
isolée et ça va être d'explorer un petit
peu la dynamique familiale de voir
comment ça se passe à la maison pour
l'enfant ou l'ado d'essayer de voir avec
les parents s'il ya d'éventuelles
difficultés
en dehors de ce que l'enfant peut
manifester dans l'établissement scolaire
et je pense que le fait de recevoir et
et les parents et l'enfant
ça amène un apaisement globale qui du
coup fin est bénéfique des deux côtés
parce que agir uniquement sur l'enfant
et ne pas finalement laissé aussi un
espace de parole aux parents c'est le
risque que l'enfant soit dans une
réitération des faits de violence à
l'établi dans l'établissement scolaire
ou à l'extérieur
d'accord d'accord parce que on a eu des
retours où on a vu qu'avec il y avait un
problème avec les parents sur l'autorité
tout ça et le fait d'avoir donc c'est ta
maison des parents d'avoir orienté par
exemple les personnes à la maison des
parents avec les enfants et pouvoir
mettre des choses en place
les relations entre les parents les
enfants se passait mieux et même les
enfants s'y sont et mieux et du coup
voilà il ya moins des faits de violence
on va dire on a presque ça tient à pas
grand chose à faire j'y vois là une
écoute juste à une échange de paroles
pas cessé de l'ecoute c'est
du bon sens aussi je pense de notre côté
de d'essayer de faire en sorte de mettre
en application des malades et des
concepts qui peuvent fonctionner c'est
aussi l'expérience sur le terrain petit
à petit on essaye aussi de construire
les choses et surtout d'être à l'écouté
autant de la population que de ce que
peuvent dire les partenaires ça recouvre
beaucoup de choses on pense évidemment
aux violences qui peuvent être exercés
de l'époux sur les pouces c'est à cela
qu'on pense essentiellement mais en
réalité ça n'est que 30 % des violences
intrafamiliales le reste c'est
effectivement des disputes et les
violences entre frères et soeurs ça peut
être sur ascendant également donc c'est
très varié c'est vrai que le domaine et
est assez vaste
je continue avec pas parler de ton dd
fait que vous receviez les auteurs
d'infractions au pénal vous m'avez aussi
parler par exemple d'un jeune qui se
trouve en possession de cannabis la
russie il ya des actions nous à leur
place
là c'est un petit peu différent c'est à
dire que on revient toujours sur
finalement un travail d'explication de
compréhension lorsque un jeunes
consomment du cannabis et qu'il est
interpellé sur la voie publique il va
faire l'objet de ce qu'on appelle donc
mis en garde à vue âgés de cannabis et
il va faire l'objet dans le même temps
la rappel à la loi les les deux choses
sont à peu près les mêmes sauf que dans
la mise en garde à l'usagé de cannabis
et bien en plus rappelé le danger du
produit et dire bien évidemment que le
produit est illégal dans le cadre de ces
procédures là ce gène est entendu par
procès verbal est en fin de procédure
lorsqu'il est mineure en fin de
procédure le civilement responsable donc
les parents doivent prendre connaissance
des déclarations de l'enfant il se
trouve que pour une partie de la
population à trappes
il y a parfois une méconnaissance de
certains termes juridiques parfois une
méconnaissance également de la langue
française
en tout cas dans ses plus grandes
difficultés
et lorsque les parents prennent
connaissance du procès de m
comprennent pas forcément mais il ne
pense pas non plus à demander des
explications et ilsinho bas du procès
verbal et quittent le commissariat les
conséquences voilà alors les
conséquences sont immédiates puisque
concrètement lorsqu'il interroge leur
fils ou leur fille puisque mécontents de
l'infraction pénale constitué l'enfant
dit écoutez moi j'ai personnellement
j'ai rien fait je me trouvais dans un
groupe de jeunes j'ai été interpellé
avec tout le monde sauf que dans le
procès verbal il est bien précisé qu'il
était effectivement détenteurs
consommateurs c'est important
donc il est important que les parents
déjà sache précisément ce que le
l'adolescent a fait ensuite il est
important également de rappeler à
l'adolescent que la consommation de ces
produits est une consommation illégale
de rappeler à l'adolescent le cadre
pénal c'est à dire ce que pourrait être
la réponse pénale du magistrat si le
magistrat avait a prononcé une réponse
pénale plus forte que celle simplement
de la mise en garde et l'usagé de
cannabis
donc il est important de remettre ce
cadre en place pour que l'on puisse
éventuellement déjà parlé de ce qu'on
appelle la théorie la dissuasion c'est à
dire de lui dire si tu réitère cette
infraction pénale
tu as plus à perdre qu'à gagner à perdre
l'emploi dans cette une partie de ta
liberté peut être être en difficulté par
rapport à l'école parce que tu aimerais
et après la cie de suite la suite dans
l'avion on comprend que le dialogue est
important
avant de terminer cette émission c'est
vrai qu'on écoute d un micro-trottoir
d'habitants on est allé dans les rues de
saint quentin pour demander en quoi pour
les gens c'était important de rapprocher
justement la police de la population a
écouté leurs réponses s'ils sont
vraiment proches de la population s'il
permet de les juger ou quoi sur leur
situation familiale koala un enfant oui
mais dans certaines limites qui essaie
de comprendre les problèmes je pense que
ça serait mieux oui meilleure
coopération entre les habitants et la
police
c'est un ça va
vivre ensemble parce que je crois qu'on
a besoin de rassurer les populations
autant qu'elles ont besoin d'être assuré
d'être entouré et et protéger les
policiers n'ont pas vraiment ce qu'il ya
des fusées mais dans la saisie du coup
je pense que c'est important ne serait
ce que l'on fait un pour eux qu'ils
puissent avoir le respect et la
reconnaissance qui leur est dû comme
pour nous pour s'en protéger et et voilà
voilà
on sent dès que c'est très important ça
va dans le sens de votre structure
psycho social implanté à trappes
je vous remercie en tout cas tous les
quatre d'être venu en plateau je
rappelle cette structure est ouverte
depuis cinq ans à trappes et elle ouvre
ou en tout cas le continue son action
maintenant sur saint quentin en yvelines
sur le district d'elancourt mais qui
couvrent l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines c'est à dire que ça
voyant son utilité c'est à dire que ça
fonctionne bien
en tout cas c'est un terme que je dirais
même qu un certain moment où sera
victime de notre succès parce qu'ils
sont que 3 d'une année sur l'autre le
nombre de contacts augmenté on aura
peut-être un jour du mal à satisfaire
ils ne sont que 3 et vous avez traité en
allant à 1200 dossiers
merci beaucoup en tout 44 d'être venue
de 117,8 société bonne soirée